okay this is something I've always
wanted to do I've seen already do it and
the theory about the training it's time
for me to just go out there and bond on
but at this point I have to prove I can
hang with this crew this is a bit insane
what I'm about to do but I know it
should work just seeing it work this
should work I'm about to grab onto
230,000 volts of electricity with my
hands while perched outside a helicopter
ride
yeah my heart is pounding
sitting out on the platform like this
I'm totally exposed
but right now the wind is the least of
my worries
for some parts of the 700 thousand mile
grid this is the only way to do the
repairs I've got to learn to do this job
right if I want to be more than just
dead weight I'm putting a lot of trust
in Eric he has to fly me into the wire
at just the right speed this is high
voltage teamwork we're putting both our
lives in the line
all set up set start over I got the
weave of the water up my wall into my
head that's right final hundred percent
of my focus the one I'm doing because it
could kill me if I don't do it right all
right I'm ready
all right
if your fear check and give you focus
a little freaky man 230
well I got a little bit of buzz in my
left hand right there feeling
just heat rating off the line mostly
just heated my hands but no big shocks
it all feels good
suits working
a world that needs power 24/7 this is
the only way to get the work done
keep the lines
do you think this mix it's easier to
easier than iron
hold it here but three four feet so it's
a breakthrough initial contact
[Music]